hey at seven I believe that if you want
to have success as an entrepreneur you
need to thank the people who are making
a positive impact on your business and
in your life and let them know you know
you they'll feel good and you'll feel
good about yourself as well so today i
want to thank Jenny moon Janie is my
media coach / trainer / awesome person
and she works at the agency that I've
retained to represent me and every week
she gets on a google chat with me and we
break down my communication skills so on
my youtube videos doing videos like this
on my radio show and anything that has
to do with communication she has really
taught me so much and every week I feel
like there's a new lesson that I'm
learning from her and we roleplay she
gives me great tips and good advice and
I really feel like without her and all
the great tips that she's given i would
be a lot further behind when I came to
the agency before I met her I thought it
was doing pretty well I thought I was
doing a good job I look at my youtube
videos people were responding they were
loving them I thought I was doing a good
job and she came in and she said listen
what you're doing is okay you could be
so much better you could do such a
better job and reach more people and
have such a great impact if you did
these things and a lot of it is
stretching outside my comfort zone it's
things that I'm not used to things that
I didn't grow up with and it's hard it
stretches me it frustrates me it angers
me and and when you're learning
something least when I'm learning
something new and I don't get it right
away it's frustrating but she's really
patient and helps me out and I just look
at my youtube videos from what I had
when I started to what I'm doing now and
you see the vast improvement and I see
the comments coming in from people of
how much it's changed their lives and
how they love the videos and they're
subscribing and and engaging with in it
makes me feel so good and a lot of that
is because of the work
that I've done with Jenny and even
looking at my radio show from when I
first started toward is now i just got
off doing my fifth episode and already
it's gotten a lot better from from where
i just started and it hasn't been that
long and so she gives me so much
information that it's hard to retain you
know like it makes sense but i have to
actually go out and do it and it's it's
changing habits which is hard but i feel
like i'm getting a lot better and more
importantly i'm able to have a bigger
impact and that's all because of journey
and i don't think i would have ever
really figured any of that stuff out or
if i did it would take me a long time
and her training and her her support and
her mentorship has meant a lot to me and
has really helped improve you know my
business and my life as well so Thank
You Janie you're awesome and I'll talk
to you next Wednesday and for those you
watching take time recognize the people
in your life we're having a lasting
impact and thank them you'll feel good
about yourself and they'll feel good as
well so take care I'll see you guys in
the next episode if you liked this video
please give it a thumbs up below and I
want to hear from you too if you have a
comment about this video or question
leave it in the comments section below
thank you guys I'll see you soon